a good day to die hard is the worst die
hard film ever made it's awful it
completely loses its charm sense a
belief
wit characters and suspenseful thrills
this just does not feel like a John
McClane adventure and as a standalone
film it's pretty [ __ ] awful the
writing is lackluster the direction is
uninspired it clearly tries to imitate
every other annoying action handheld
film this movie is like three action
scenes no I'm not saying this movie only
has three action scenes which it does
I'm saying this movie is only three
action scenes with a couple of scenes of
dialogue despite all the chaos Bruce
Willis still looks completely bored
throughout everything and apparently the
older he gets the more invincible he
becomes Jai Courtney is Bruce Willis the
son that's about it the villain is not
interesting the twists and turns have no
impact
this film is just loud obnoxious strikes
out on balancing serious moments with
fine action but for some reason I really
enjoyed this big pile of [ __ ]
technically speaking it's just a bad
movie but I must say and I don't know
why I did enjoy the old bored Bruce
Willis and this 90-minute ride but still
all in all I gotta say a good day to die
hard got it wrong